if this ain't making your dick hard
I don't know what's wrong with you and
everyone's like what our guest is a
huge get I shout out to black Lu
I mean the guy super producer making a
world of fans in the campers community
here with the bonfire you know how there
it is
you know you love him I've been on the
road they've been asking about him a lot
of people thanked me for bringing us in
their life on the phone all the way from
am I correct Brazil Brashear Brazil it's
Sean Furey everybody Sean Furey on the
bonfire how you doing Sean Furey all
right we're doing pretty good man
usually there's a whole applause thing
but our engineer decided to go away and
left to confuse young man on the board
yeah we got our backup quarterback on
the board today but that's all right I
guess he's better than the quarterbacks
the Jets have had those five years oh no
it's okay no one here's a fan of the
Jets are we're all you know I know the
feeling I'm you know I'm a New York New
Jersey guy but the Steelers have always
been liking you got it Elizabeth New
Jersey you stomping grounds well I was
born and raised educated in New York but
you know most of Julian's or former New
Yorkers who can't escape yeah you can I
got about the country yeah
now what made you out now we've been
going through your catalog here on the
show for a few weeks now yeah I think we
first started with biracial
the video our front des show the video
biracial and then we found a live
performance and then we found our way to
your YouTube channel and we just went
real deep we had a whole Sean Furey day
you know we got into it and that's why
you're such a big because our fans love
you and we got into it thank you thank
you I mean there's some questions we
definitely have some questions because
as I said we we went in deep now I can't
help but notice the the video for the
song it's uh she said no no no does this
have anything to do with the reason
you're out of the country right now
no no no they wouldn't let the brothers
get on the plane if that was a happiness
but especially if you know you know the
history of our country so you know black
man white woman he's not going to make
it you know this that's why I guess cogs
going to jail right yeah Wow yeah I mean
there's many reasons but that was the so
wait.you doled out justice yourself
though and the she said no no no video
at the end oh yeah well actually
actually whatever I do my videos I I
always try to keep it real just like
anytime I write my music I want the real
stories there you know this is the
people next door people you know people
you've seen on the bus the train the
people you gave the middle finger to
while you're driving in the car you know
these are real things that happen and I
always try to keep things real so you do
you do do dole out vigilante justice on
rapists I would if I was in the you know
if it was a situation and I saw it and
I'm right there I'm gonna do so okay
sometimes you have to be hesitant
because you know I've seen an experience
where a guy was smacking up his
girlfriend in the street now I'm like
four or five blocks away and I have one
this big bomber so let me look like I'm
hoping you know and so he's smacking her
up and I'm getting closer I'm hearing
the conversation you know cuz you have
to be careful because you might beat up
the boyfriend and she turns around
starts cutting you up and the other one
going to jail and everybody's going home
and you're you're the idiot yes I think
that's a soul I think you just wrote a
new song right there in that story yeah
so this guy is getting smacked
Miska this woman's getting smacked up
and her friend is like yeah girl you
can't don't take this from him and he's
backing up slam it on spaceman today and
there's police across the street
nobody's know anything and then as I'm
getting closer and and then I hear him
speak and he says and you cheated on me
for what you slapped and I was like oh
wait a minute I can't
get into this right now this is a little
little bit deep for me and then put the
girlfriend her girlfriend is still
provoking this man like you don't do
this and I'm looking and I'm like at
what point does this guy turn around and
realize that his girlfriend is not doing
anything but the one that's talking is
provoking him he should just leave you
know yeah and so by the time like I got
up there cuz then I start to run to get
over there it's all broken up they jump
in the car and I'm and I'm saying this
is real stuff you know people don't
write about stuff like this yeah you are
shown if I can ask you a question mr.
fury black Lu who you spoke with on the
phone I know black Lu would tell you
that his stairway to heaven will always
be the song snow you wrote on your album
that would that my favorite titles may
be on any album ever if you can bring
that up Christine the ladies of color
album ladies of color yes I mean writing
a song for every shade of woman in the
beautiful rainbow now the balls the
balls mr. fury that I believe you showed
in the writing in the titling a song
Indian / Arabic girl my favorite part in
the song being when you say when you
sing the word / in you say my Indian /
Arabic girl is one of the most fun
lyrics I've ever heard in my entire life
well actually I sat down years ago and I
always try to be different for everyone
else and when I realized that that I was
beating all types of limits I was
collecting notes in my head and I wanted
to see and share that they all have some
of the same needs and desires but they
just do things just a little bit
different it's not too much of a
difference if they can't stand their
boyfriend or their husband they let you
know yeah the same just different smells
yeah was it it's a you know it's a
universal thing
I mean I don't care the meekest woman
that you can find if you leave that
toilet seat ah would you consider this
would you consider ladies of color a
concept album yeah let's put it this way
for the guys who have a hard time
speaking to women what they should do
for example a guy oh I'm into these
pipes I don't know what the thing yeah
if I'm like I'm like what if I meet a
girl my neighborhood and I'm like she's
in Indian or Arabic how do it what song
do I do or a clue throw it on go to
recognize black loose entities of color
is this generation as the wall yeah now
I call it Purple Rain it's a the songs
are so entertaining I love the year
feature in the videos can you I don't
know if you can I don't know if you can
be honest here but these girls in the
videos what percentage of them usually
you broke off in real life even he's
counting on his hands
that's hilarious
he goes oh sorry man he had to this
one there's no way yeah what he's
listening to Sirius XM right now in
Brazil last names fury yeah I believe
that comes from fuel steam follow the
money follow the paper trail let's find
out this guy's real name but it's also
mark vengeance as possible yeah let's
keep digging yeah that's his alter ego
look funk dig until we hit bedrock yeah
nobody apologize to you Bert we brought
you in to this
I guess not as well-versed yeah so Sean
Furey was a guy where we found out one
video dude that lady's got straight-up
raped in that video
it's graphic it's vivos graphics the
accused looks like a kid's movie it
really does yeah I would almost show
that at like to scare teenagers you show
that video you know that's what happens
and they're like I don't like this did
you want yeah yeah I might as well do a
cocktail yeah I feel I feel like
I feel like I'm
firing hot yeah yeah hell yeah come on I
mean what's he doing in Brazil well ma
that's why he asked about this video cuz
it could be because of this video or
cookies just going to see some butts is
he on the phone today pick back up or
J's hang up cuz he does like J's
inappropriate questions for an artiste
you don't say if they broke him off J
mask how many of these women are his did
he bed down did he bet hey Shawn we lost
you now you're back we're just watching
the video for smells like my comeback
you know I'm here boom then I'm gone
right now you're back let me finish what
I was saying I'm gonna address that know
the girls in biracial no no that's
actually my wife and she was pregnant
with our twins when I did that so I
can't be breaking off anybody I was
gonna say that just killed the that just
killed the the legend the legend of Sean
Furey there really you should you got to
keep that hidden away from the world man
yeah you can't even you're a sexpot
really when when you hear what I'm
writing on the news you know and all
these guys cheating on their lives you
know I got the countess cheating if you
do it in Brazil the count is cheating if
you do it in Brazil then you have to
look at what's what your what your real
focus is do you really want to go out
there and cheat on your spouse I mean
for years for example you've heard
people say oh practice safe sex well if
you have to practice it you're not good
at it okay so if you have to practice
being safe you're not good at it so be a
professional just live dangerously is
that you're saying so let me answer one
more question because I I try to address
everything I always try to keep things
keep it real and not real phony
she said no
whatever I do my videos I'm an equal
opportunist I try to bring together
everybody that all the different types
and what goes on there in a community
originally the cast was supposed to be
all Latino and I was supposed to come in
and still do my hero thing yeah the
funny thing about it is I always kept
backups for my videos these people will
show up at this certain time then you
got the job and let's go let's go
you know you offered Latinos and they
didn't take it well then they blew it
they didn't show up you know so now cuz
I always tell them I always tell them
you know in the video from the start I
said you're gonna be famous
cuz I like to keep real people it's easy
to get supermodels who are starving to
death you know and they look all hot and
you're like all there yeah but that's
the same guy that's the same girl that
was in Santos video no people I like to
use real people doing real things
telling real stories ample when I find
interesting about the video the video is
quite graphic and the song has such a a
bubbly tone to it yeah almost like a
beach tune but it's then scored on top
of a video that's very dramatic and very
graphic yeah well I mean you give me a
real DeNiro level
Goodfellas beating yeah that's a it's a
real stomping and I love the choice of
showing throwing the shirt to him yeah
like clean yourself up yeah well here's
the thing with that with the video I
mean most people expect a heavy song
like that to be a ballad yeah I mean do
you really want to be romanced by a song
so sexual but it's how it's a horrible
act yeah but when you hear it bouncing
it's grabbing your attention and you're
saying wait a minute he's really going
into detail with this and you in and
that definitely now you're in you're
really getting the message because I'm
not endorsing it no
you know what anti-rape yeah yeah
exactly
yes Sean shows up at the end oh yeah
okay yep hey do you read some of the
stuff people say you would think oh my
god what was it he's she's probably
fantasizing about this oh my god
he probably masturbates to this oh my
god I do fine without that I was doing
fine before I was married I was doing
I'm doing fine while I'm there you know
the funny thing about it it's a serious
topic and most people don't realize the
emails that I receive that's what I'm
curious about is the pushback yeah give
me more emails that go like I'm walking
to the store oh man I can't believe the
yeah the like probably stuff like what
is he doing in an abandoned apartment
that doesn't even that apartment looks
condemned where is this furniture yeah
who's this girl why does he look so
actually frightened why is it why is it
got to be a black guy and a white girl
what what bone deficiency does this
villain have why does he have bird chest
and you know it and this is and this is
the reality but when this when this
thing came out a lot of women wrote to
me and they said I never thought about
no they never thought about they've been
some of them wrote to me and said I've
been to trap houses with some of my
friends and I never thought about them
I've been to frat houses I never thought
about that
and I'm like well it's usually a guy you
know yeah and you have these
preconceived notions and then when it
came down to it just happened to be
black man and a white woman well I did
that one I was just a guy pulling the
trigger the God did that because I knew
from the black community I like oh my
god it always got to be the brothers
feeling this going down and from the
white community I got see I know I know
I know it's my neighbor next door he
wants to F me I
neighbor they're always looking at you
like oh they're out there watering their
lawns just like us they have secrets we
all know please for me I bet I've always
been blessed to experience a lot of
people I grew if you if you ever get a
hole and I'm pretty sure people who grew
up with me I saw pictures in and when I
went to school and my elementary school
it looked like a UNICEF poster so I I've
heard every kind of ethnic slur and name
coming across to everybody so knowing
what their hangups
knowing how they felt how they dealt
with it in we all find people you have
different reactions the things I think
because like black Lew who works here in
studio with us will tell us that uh you
know white kids growing up used to get
timeout when they got in trouble yeah
but uh black kids got timeout timeout
from whooping that ass yeah that's that
Israel yeah you know what else is real
is like our producer our producer
Christine and you know it's not only
just race it's also gender because like
our producer Christine will always tell
us like you know women be shopping you
can't stop a woman from shopping that's
right I've had many of these some parts
of the planets in the interactions
anything well you speak with good
diction I said I'm not that type of guy
I'm not introduced there's like what did
you just say to me you're like well then
I have to say I'll translate it to you I
speak this way because ten minutes ago I
was just eating a white woman so I
haven't quite digested it will come out
and then they tell their friends and
they're like Becky Chad come over here
hey everybody get around stop playing
frisbee we talked about this black guy
eating white women yeah
that's how real it is but then again a
lot of my white friends
what more were some of them were more
blacker than black people be like yes I
do we like yo I know you know I know you
think I smell like wet dog right right
they won't even say that they would say
they would you would think I would not
planning this because in the
neighborhood I grew up in okay we were
so tight and so close that anybody
coming in from the outside you know we
could call each other names but nobody
from the outside could come in and do
that
they're like somebody's cousin came in
and he starts calling somebody this and
they say hey man keep that in check
that's my friend and you know just call
some Asian guy something and some Puerto
Rican guy comes out smoking today
yeah you never know where it's gonna
catch it Shawn have you ever thought
about putting this all together in one
one-man show to hit the stage with it
voices are amazing about producing a
movie so everybody can see the road I
took cause it's not easy the gatekeepers
don't let somebody in like me what they
want they want a Sean Furey and that's
not my ego talking but they want that
yeah but they want they want
you to be there you know sarn here do
this before you know all your money's
going ain't give me all your black magic
I'm gonna turn it into green gold
yeah they show you the door they're like
this door some of your favorite fat
people are doing things you don't want
to see oh well and then in the fifth or
the exit they get the hell out of here
yeah let's I mean let's really do the
voice right there like this door has all
the people inside doing bad stuff this
door is the exit I've always been the
type of guy to stand on my own do it
myself and I have the persistence and I
teach my kids the same thing I say
listen you want us to be successful you
only need two things
that's desire and determination you have
those two things you're going to you're
going to go places it'll take you longer
trying to the right
but you'll get there a little laugh Sean
Furey I 100% agree with you on that
hell yeah buddy we really appreciate you
calling in more big fans you are next
level pop locker I really think you
should be doing like putting this
together in stage are you doing shows
while you're in Brazil you everything
you want to plug yeah I'm actually doing
some we're working on some other things
because in the Sean Furey story there's
been I I actually recorded some stuff I
sent LJ some some music because a lot of
people say oh he's trying to do Michael
Jackson he's trying to do that you know
I'm a fan of everybody to Mike before me
during me and after me and it hasn't
been released it's an homage to Michael
because I actually wrote a couple of
songs when if you've seen the video on
the thriller I actually wrote to perform
with Michael but then he died I'm sorry
thriller no you know what wait a minute
what I've got stories that you guys
wouldn't even believe and the people
that were there will tell you that it's
hilarious I'll tell you a quick quick
story it won't be a Bill Cosby like when
it would be like I almost had a fight
with Mike Tyson and this was fresh after
he broke up with Robin so you know he
was a little little different then oh
yeah he was ready to go he was ready to
rock he would camp that I would get in
my way
a Bobby Brown party and this chick was
screaming at him at the top of her lungs
come he was messing around with them
other chicks in the VIP room okay Here I
am Here I am I see him earlier because
I'm in the VIP room I used to get into
these clubs people thought I was Ralph
Tresvant from new addition I used to get
into a lot of clubs I used to get guys
want to beat me up thinking I was Ralph
Tresvant from the Commission if I show
you some earlier photos put him there
Burton I definitely see it and so he
late to make a long story short I ran
into him later on that night and his
chick was making this man's face contort
into five different pieces and he looked
at me like he wanted then put a hole in
my chest with his fist and I told the
man you know how it is in VIP if you're
in the VIP room you can't be soft
because people start treating you like
you soften you know it's like prison
rules are like the yard
you know what goes on the rules what
happens in VIP stays in VIP you damn
right but this story is so hilarious if
you see it you like no it could not have
happened like that way and so I'm
standing there and me being from New
York you know New Yorkers they have an
attitude they have a will play that
you know he's from hopefully that
you don't play that so I turned
around in this man grabbed my mom I told
them because everybody's watching me and
they watching him they gonna see how
this we actually probably don't remember
this and he said I said to him I said
calm down
baby if you lose 200 pounds I will bust
your ass like I said I tried to walk off
like I was Bruce Lee you know and
everybody look at me like wow he said
that nice delivered yeah and my
friend stepped away from me when I said
that I had friends one of my friends was
like Wilson he's tall and everybody just
said excuse me and they moved out of the
way to let this man decide whether he
wants to put me in the hospital but I'm
I'm trying around like I whip everybody
dancing here
now quite naturally if he lost 200
pounds I would have outweighed him and
and that day I was in fact that alright
I'm not like Martin fat Martin your
skinny Martin so I turned around and
this man tan took up all of my forearm
and he grabbed me and I'm looking and he
can't see my face and I said ah
I started to fight I turned he was like
[Laughter]
thank you very much can I plant one seed
your next music video I know two guys
who would love to be the actors in it
this is Bert Kreischer secret times new
specials at on Netflix right now
comedy special yeah you guys
you guys set it up hey I'll put up you
know I'd love to do a comedy show on
some movies and everything like that you
guys are connected there you know I mean
you guys could use comedy central's will
pick the song will pick the song and we
want you to direct it like you normally
do you're in your artistic view and
we'll be the actors oh we got a big cast
here perfect that's seven cast members
hey we can we can put that together you
know and I'm very I'm very grateful that
comes from the bottom of my heart that
you guys you know pushing me because you
know sometimes I I still get people
emailing and all kinds of stuff just
like show me your music
it's it's crazy it's like how haters are
gonna hate showing you know that you
know you should tell him lose 200 pounds
I'll you up
that should be the title of a song lose
200 pounds I'll you up Sean you
have a great time in Brazil be careful
some of the prettiest chicks there are
dudes but that that really could be a
whole new concept to helping my friend
Sean Furey joining us on the but
everybody thank you so much Sean go to
Sean Furey comm check out all of his
stuff we are big fans we don't here on
the bonfire
let's call back let's uh let's take a
break yeah let's take a break we'll come
back come back and we'll talk with Bert
Kreischer and I had a feeling this next
hours gonna fly yeah that was the
temptations my girl his song is called
my girl is for me he ain't saying he
wrote the temptations my brilliant if
you ever heard his song welcome to the
jungle oh dude yeah I mean he wrote one
of my favorite songs comfortably no
goddammit
not that one though it meant like that
comfortably now yeah yeah he's
misspelled numb uh I could only say
probably the best interview we've ever
done I mean gripping never had rivet
already said I wrote thriller I was like
are you saying you wrote through
he's like no like I was I was the
asshole like oh you just said you wrote
thriller he goes ah well you do by the
way a lot of girls watch that video and
go I never thought about that
yeah a frat house and at first I thought
he said a trap house here in a crack
house and you don't think you don't
think they're selling drugs there might
be some rape going on occasionally
people ain't we're gonna talk about the
real shoot dude
can I just tell you right now I was
blown away by that interview at multiple
points in the interview was I was I a
little like oh this really got this
guy is who he really is
blown away by what she's had but then I
realized the delusion comes because I
don't think he knows how large our
audience is I love the size of our
audience but he was like guys getting
the blogs after me I'm like no no it's
not gonna happen dude
it's gonna
to do it the value of our our show the
value we sighs we've got a bunch of
blogs written about things on the show
good or bad you know yeah but I don't
know think I write what about Sean a
blog about this that's what he said he's
like oh you guys are gonna get the press
all over me Oh Matt saw yeah I mean here
Brazil trying to give back with my
family by the way every time you ask
them a funny question
there is a five-minute wait to rebuttal
you always go and you know it yeah that
was great job LJ LJ you Larry
Johnson you're no longer black Lou okay
can I simply say one thing yeah yeah I
don't think he's in Brazil you think
he's just in Paterson New Jersey just
take a call by the way that might be the
most brilliant thing I'll start doing
what I do call it call him from an
international why wouldn't you say that
Lou had to call him on one of those like
zero zero zero
something one four eight I'm gonna start
telling people I'm in Brazil do it I
like it
and well you know what besides us in the
listeners there listen oh I won't blow
it for you
why don't you talk to Burt where in the
world is he hey guys it's Burt I'm in
Paris it's like a Scott Peterson thing
yeah Thailand I'm in Bangkok right now
for the weekend I've been a hot-air
balloon over Deutschland I'm in red a
the Reykjavik funny bone Oh
for Thursday Friday hit Saturday how
funny oh my god I'm gonna set up
a press tour on phone and just get sound
effects yeah it's the interview that you
could tell they don't give a about
you like what are you up to
Kreischer in the background you here
come with me I usually go skewb first
thing guys shut up Blanca what are you
saying scootering the buzz on mornings
on I'm on the I'm on the phone Ohio's
number one rock station with the bone up
next we got Bert Kreischer Bert
Kreischer how are you doing
Bert Kreischer : oh he's in Siberia I
forgot he's doing a weekend oh sorry I
can't talk about Fight Club wait no I
can't nothing oh you know what I'm
nowhere it just told me again
he doesn't like he's here to rule - yeah
they just said it again I can't talk
about it
I heard Zack Galifianakis do a call-in
one time and he had a chainsaw with him
that is awesome and he called in and
they're like we gotta hold on and you
just hit the chainsaw and he goes sorry
we're building a tree house
yeah that's great I think you should go
International for now wouldn't you have
more fun with your Carlin's I mean Sean
Furey is just straight-up international
he was wonderful what do you think what
do you think production costs on one of
his videos five grand
$200 what are you talking about Kate
retired about catering for everyone
those involved 135 dollars I'll show you
right now all right as God is my witness
yeah I would pay I'll pay five thousand
dollars if I can put it on my youtube
channel yeah to produce a Sean Furey
video with all of us in it Sean doing
the singing to the camera and all of us
are acting out the scene behind them can
we write a father write the story of the
video I want Sean to do it you're right
I'm so sorry yeah
you